financial debt can be one of the biggest
worries if you find yourself not knowing
what to do with those debts and
considering bankruptcy eric palacio from
eric palacios and associates the
sponsors of this segment is here to help
welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney
eric palacios today we're going to tell
you three types of debt that can be
eliminated with a bankruptcy we all know
credit card debt can be eliminated but
the other three debts are number one
medical bills any hospital doctor
emergency room or ambulance bill can be
eliminated with a chapter 7 bankruptcy
number two foreclosures and
repossessions if your home has been
foreclosed or you're behind on the
payments and don't wish to keep it you
can give it up and eliminate the debt
with the bankruptcy the same thing goes
for a car that has been repossessed or
that you're behind on the payments and
you don't want to keep the car
number three
payday loans or personal loans we know
that interest rates on these loans are
very very high and they're difficult to
pay down this debt can also be
eliminated in a bankruptcy this has been
the legal minute don't forget to
download my free app eric palacio's
legal app
thanks again to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
for more information you can give them a
call at 702-444-7777